after an excruciatingly long wait eddie
brock and venom have finally returned to
theaters so let's dig in and talk about
the ending of venom let there be carnage
obviously many spoilers lie ahead
there's gonna be carnage
cletus cassidy believes that people love
a serial killer just ask him
people love serial killers
see by the end of the film cletus has
had carnage run roughshod all over him
lost the only woman he has ever loved
and finally revealed his true motive he
just wanted to be eddie's friend i miss
you
so much
as venom is quick to point out that
position is already filled which is most
likely why after nearly two hours of
doing battle with him venom chomps off
cletus's head sorry cletus it was fun
while it lasted as for the issue of
carnage a crawling ball of goo searching
desperately for a new host venom takes
care of that problem too scooping up the
red sludge venom sucks it up like a
slurpee in the comics of course carnage
is like a bad penny who just keeps
turning up but in the venom franchise at
least for the foreseeable future cletus
and carnage both seem like they've taken
that long last trip to the distant
cathedral
fans were thrilled to learn that francis
barrison would be a key character in
venom let there be carnage and even more
thrilled to learn that she'd be brought
to life by naomi harris harris is a
veteran actor who is shined in films as
varied as skyfall and moonlight fans
will undoubtably be happy with the
result as the character more commonly
known as shriek features prominently
throughout the film as the bonnie to
cassidy's clyde cackling with glee as
the ill-fated lovers go on a
super-powered killing spree by the end
of the movie however the love triangle
of cletus francis and carnage is
beginning to show some strain for
starters shriek's main weapon is a brain
scrambling scream that doesn't pair well
with symbiote's sensitivity to high
sonic energy every time carnage seems to
be getting into a groove shriek lets out
a scream knocking the big red guy off
his game after she seemingly dispatches
detective mulligan shriek has one final
confrontation with the two symbiotes
echoing earlier comic book appearances
of venom this smackdown involves a
massive church bell whose every ring
pummels the senses of the symbiotes
knocked off her perch during the battle
shriek falls to her seeming death
a great deal of let there be carnage
concerns itself with the uneasy highly
non-traditional relationship between
eddie and venom sharing a goal an
apartment and a body the duo undoubtably
get on each other's nerves but need each
other to survive and thrive by the end
of the film this odd couple seems to
have finally made up the immediate
villains are gone and they've turned
their focus on the next adventure one
that will seemingly interact with
spider-man no way home but first venom
needs some well-deserved r r perhaps not
since the training scene of rocky iii as
it felt so good to watch two heroes
frolicking together on a beach most
importantly venom has indeed come out of
the so-called eddie brock closet for
good the journalist seems more
comfortable with letting his freak flag
fly as long as venom does its best to
only feast on those who really really
deserve it
a key character in this film is
detective mulligan played by the always
excellent always intense character actor
stephen graham in the opening scenes of
carnage we see a young mulligan
attempting to thwart and escape by
shriek shooting her in the eye but
nearly losing his life in the process
clearly francis barrison knows how to
hold a grudge as decades later shriek
pins a detective to the ground and
presses a thumb into his eye after the
perceived death of shriek we see a very
brief shot that not only indicates
graham is still alive but that he might
also now be super powered what does this
mean who could mulligan become fans will
undoubtedly spend the immediate
aftermath of the film's release pouring
over possibilities perhaps we could
start the conversation by throwing out
one toxin in the 2004 venom carnage
miniseries carnage created toxin who
then bonded with an nypd cop named
patrick mulligan mulligan ended up
talking things out with spider-man and
agreeing to try and harness the symbiote
who could be considered venom's grandson
to fight crime it's also well known that
in the comics shriek can use her powers
to simply turn people evil so perhaps
mulligan is merely now an evil mulligan
perhaps the most significant revelation
in the final moments of let there be
carnage comes at the end this mid-credit
sequence depicts venom and eddie in a
hotel room together watching foreign
language soap operas as the two begin
exchanging thoughts on the show they're
watching venom makes an intoxicating
offer what if you were to give eddie
brock just the tiniest glimpse of all
that's going through his superior brain
eddie opts in once venom begins to
download the room starts spinning lights
start flashing and eddie wakes up in a
very different room this one's playing a
different program on the television sure
enough it's j jones jameson making his
multiverse shattering announcement that
spider-man is really peter parker venom
gets in close to the tv to take in the
news and when he sees parker he begins
to lick the television i want spider-man
as fans have seen in the no way home
trailer jameson's announcement is the
catalyst for everything that happens in
that film causing peter to seek out dr
strange to presumably meddle with the
multiverse in a way that allows such
previous franchise threats as doctor
octopus and electro to once again pose a
threat of course the venom we see in
these tom hardy films is a lot nicer
than the character is typically
portrayed but even if he's putting the
hero an anti-hero it seems likely that
venom will not be approaching spider-man
with a tentacle extended in friendship
at the very least this mid-credits
sequence establishes that this film's
conclusion coincides with the far from
home opening which makes a crossover
feel quite inevitable check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about venom are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]